- [Kelly] You did get to meet
Priscilla Presley, right?
- [Austin] Yeah.
- What was that like?
Was it intimidating?
- Super intimidating,
but she didn't make it intimidating.
I met her the same day
I went to Grayson for the first time.
- I've never been.
- [Austin] You've never been?
- No! And I lived
Tennessee for like years.
I just don't know, work.
- Yeah, it's so great.
Baz and I took this road trip
right after I got the part.
We went and recorded in Nashville,
it was the first recording
studio I was ever in,
- It's a great place to record.
- It was RCA Studio B there.
Where Dolly Parton recorded Jolene.
- Oh my gosh.
- Elvis recorded over
270 songs, I believe.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- So we took this road trip
and ended up in Grayson
and next door there was this hotel
where I met Priscilla,
and she was just so beautiful
and so warm and welcoming.
And she just gave me a big hug
and said, you have a lot of support.
And I walked out of that hotel room
just with tears in my eyes.
Just thinking, it's amazing
when you look into her eyes
and you you think this is the same woman
that Elvis was madly in love with.
That she was madly in love with him.
She's the mother of his only child,
and then she's right here in front of me.
It's really surreal.
We got to go to the MET Gala recently
and we kind of danced a bit,
and she's the best, she's incredible.
- [Kelly] I love that.
You seem very present.
Are you always that present
in thinking like that?
In life?
Like, you know, just being
in the moment like that,
not people many people are like that.
- I try to be, it's hard
with what we do sometimes.
- I'm working at it and I
just turned 40 Austin, so-
(Kelly laughs)
- Well, you look amazing.
- Well, thank you for lying.
(audience laugh)
but thank you so much, Austin.
Everybody, we need another break.
Go see Elvis, it's in theaters tomorrow.
You won't regret it!